[Music]
it still takes 45 seconds for Pixar and
Disney logos to jerk each other off
this is agent Leland Java Pixar takes
the dock hollywood-style story of cars
and makes the sequel spy movie like its
King James Bond I'm sure on paper it
sounds really sweet but sometimes you
have to make an entire movie to figure
that out
this is Pixar so I'm sure these
coordinates are accurate for some place
in the Pacific Ocean but who cares the
latitude and longitude
I haven't had to care about that since I
aced my fifth grade geography class and
forgot all about it
okay fun he found a way to sneak over
the other ship when no one was looking
the problem is the ship he's hanging on
to with alive and probably has feeling
good so how does he hook onto another
sentient vehicles flesh without that guy
knowing then faces pop ova movie also
errors in spending way too many opening
minutes on characters we don't know
headlight based zoom in and enhance
cliche although we are living in the
world where the crates did unload
themselves we wouldn't ban it on even if
you could do this why would you do this
you had a perfect look into what this
operation was and got crystal-clear
audio the only reason you do this is so
you can get caught for movie purposes -
done double here folks - tons above see
why does this car fall to absolute
pieces upon hitting the water but the
pieces still maintain their basic body
shape if every car on this rig was
following him up the ramp that just
exploded then huh are there any cars up
here at the top ready to chase after it
about a minute ago we just saw a car
explode from the surface tension so how
does fin survive an even higher jump is
it because of his Greg Louganis style
form as he enters the water because I'm
pretty sure the surface tension does
give it about your four Olympic gold
medals here's a car operating a gun on
board a boat and again I raised my
concerns about how the screen vehicle
Society works why is a car accenting
enough to fire a boat gun but the boat
itself is not got all the cool spy
gadgets man that comes with the
territory in spy movies but if he could
do this why did he need to hitch a ride
on a boat could have gone completely
stealth mode underwater all the way up
to the rig who can stop us now
major tow major that - That moment when
you realize mater is the sequel's main
character instead of lightning I thought
I could make it this time kind of cars
that break down in the middle of the
desert call for help advantage humans
assholes because when our cars break
down we still have legs and sometimes
phones this is your tan tone as much so
that means it's on the house what kind
of ass face tow company has a rewards
policy we're your tenth tow in a month
is free literally no one in the entire
US gets towed ten times a month except
characters written by screenwriter later
is a dick
the Queen back yet will be literally
imitates conversations between children
and their parents almost nine minutes
into this car sequel crazy excited about
20th for a festive cup expositional
towing mater is as excited as a puppy to
see McQueen to the point he's about to
kill the guy you do it is so good to see
you buddy speak for yourselves
I can't believe I renamed a piston cup
after our very own dog guts
how is this new doesn't everybody watch
the piston cup certainly this town would
follow lightning and get word that they
renamed the cup and Doc's honor since
he's from here but then appalled Neumann
died a couple years after cars but how
did his character die mother I was in
tip-top shape
this asshole Otis can keep driving
around and breaking down on the side of
the road really doc could do better than
that feel like they could say move to
some faraway Island to get the same
effect
hey we find out this is some dickhead
playing a practical joke but that means
this asshole has been sitting here in
the tunnel on the off chance cars are
driving down the tracks tireless mater
enlightening film a recruiting
commercial for the Prometheus school of
running away from things it's kinda
offshoot of count tipping raises more
questions than answers like why is a
sentient vehicle out in the pasture
sleeping like an animal also what the
machine this big doing out this bump
tiny ass counselor noting the incredible
Beals is probably ten times better than
this movie NATO is officially the cable
guide level of creepy
showing up to lightning and Sally's date
as a waiter and yes I know he's being
played by Larry the Cable Guy but I met
the Jim Carrey character pun not
intended to show the world what is new
super fuel can do he's created a racing
competition like no other and but why
not just scientifically demonstrate your
fuels benefits on our YouTube video you
definitely don't need a host of car
breaks and how all these competitors be
able to run on your new fuel without
having advanced time to test it and see
how their engine reacts
you're bringing mater right you never
bring them to any of your races that's
racist let me see if I have this right
lightning is chillin on vacation at all
but some open-wheel race bitch brags on
lightning and mater just happens to be
watching so he calls in to challenge
that ragging do lightning comes to see
what the fuss is about sees his friend
getting dissed on TV and then agrees to
a road course race challenge out of pure
defensive mater and no concept of the
race itself and that's how this movie
kicked its main plot into gear I mean
not using a car song for this montage is
a little too on-the-nose
the cars rule the cars movies do not
let's not confuse the two for younger
generations also this is a relationship
song more likely a breakup song where
the singer says all I want is you to a
girl or boy he's in love with but this
is a travel montage making the song
choice even more confusing oh and by the
way the same band has a song called
drive FYI see I'm just being a dick to
cartoons giving me funny details when I
want to travel montage but was made her
meet with a travel pillow everyone on
this plane is asleep except lightning
and mater and they're awake because
they're watching Japanese Ninja Warrior
for cars I guess this movie is soaking
offensively terrible Jesus lightning
McQueen is on a giant billboard here but
no one recognizes and driving the common
streets among the normals fact here's
Lightning McQueen and a store dedicated
the merchandise about him yet he is
still on Mob check out that tow truck
man I wonder who that guys with cars to
is seriously about to try and ring
emotional conflict out of lightning
being embarrassed by mater's higness
which not only the first movie cover but
is also a bit of a cliche storyline
anyway Jeannie and I get vigilant yeah
either suddenly wants to be friends with
the asshole you just yelled at on
national TV for the disrespect towards
his best friend is this his character I
think is annoying is he is this is not
something he would do hey look it's that
spy car from the opening about whom I
remember nothing taking on the biggest
oil reserve in the world how did we miss
that
they've been scrambling everyone
satellite all-american is here tonight
to pass it to you why would some
important spot be happening here in the
preamble to the big race why isn't this
exchange happening somewhere that
secluded is it so there will be a
hilarious mixup with mater where he
becomes relevant to the story
hugs down there were on the oil platform
if they see me the whole mission is
compromised in it even further reason
why no top secret exchanges would be
happening in public places like this ah
he's a little excited soon a joke how
Shrek uh via Pixar sequel straight from
a wasabi misunderstanding joke into a
pee joke I refused to believe Hong
Kong's bathroom door symbols for gender
or this vague this is just more
manufactured confusion to create mater
hilariousness this movie seriously aired
on what it thought people might have
enjoyed about the first one like super
hard air
I'm could he possibly have seen that
would lead to this reaction everyone is
driving around this place naked and
again left wondering why a car thus
guides needs to get out of disguise for
any reason ever especially for something
like this
mater is oblivious to this battle
because he's the been sidetracked by
this first but but the day experienced
whatever you do I would not go in there
mater takes a second to pay homage days
spent or prepare to meet work this is
the exact same thing that happened to me
the last time I visited a porn set a
Volkswagen Karmann Ghia has no radiator
well of course it does that goes it's
Erica yep the spies came up with pass
phrases that are easily answered by
anyone with knowledge of cars it's fine
somewhere more private well yeah I know
cars to make spine look even harder than
it already is why do you have HD video
surveillance of basically everywhere but
no audio which would tell you that mater
is not the second agent you have
mistaken important also I saw the man
who knew too little and I'm looking down
at you for basically doing a car based
ripoff of that movie all along making
its debut tonight is the required fuel
again and I do think this is worth
sitting twice how do you force cars to
race on your new fuel without giving
them time beforehand to test it out so
now the two most drummed up participants
in this race Lightning and Francesco are
both starting the race in the very last
two spot for the back of the pack why
they so favorite if they pulled so
poorly is to be last at the starting
line now the is there a camera in front
of lighten queen that is faster than him
in order to record this why is he in the
pit
he's so exposed it's amazing to me that
these spies were just seen hanging up in
public suddenly good about where other
spies are hanging out under this analogy
is stupid
I want a roll bar an inanimate object be
excited about the prospect of being
repeatedly put to the test
even when protecting a human a roll bar
is going to suffer during a car crash
right pain imp scratches mostly I just
think this is a super lazy car based
analogy and I wanted to call it out the
M keys work on electronic devices and
equipment this movie will suggest the
gasoline in these cars somehow reacts
negatively to the EMP as though there is
electronics inside the gasoline when
really an EMP would stop a car
regardless of fuel because modern cars
are all electronically controlled so
this fuel additive of death is just
pointless and stupid looks like this
entire sequel ya got now I usually like
to have a proper detailing then or I
mean a lady friend
somehow mater is coaxed into getting out
of the pits just because this beautiful
lady car begs him to do it
and yeah the power of car boners is
probably strong but enough to get made
her away from his best friend's race but
he's leading and it's almost over but I
know that Finn is a high priority target
for the bad guys but they are
specifically looking for mater right now
he's the one with the thing that they
need so why is the entire bad guy grew
going after Finn Tom leaned ahead toward
a truck mater who's been thinking with
his car dick this entire time decides
not to follow shift Wells instructions
in this instance a Bharati damaged I
mean your stupidity is kind of a
liability for this movie it works in
small doses but this is cringe-worthy
and generally insulting I lost the race
because of you we're supposed to believe
that lightning learned his lesson from
the first movie so well that he's
repeated this piston cup champion four
times but he's just as dickish in this
movie as he wasn't the last one it was
barely redeemable in the first cars now
he's maybe worse don't need your help
I don't want your help movie rips off
the telling off of Encino man from
Encino man which basically ripped off
the shooting of Old Yeller from Old
Yeller which basically ripped off the
Abraham Isaac story from the Bible which
basically Ben Mac Messiah British
intelligence khomeini averaging telling
Mater grisly overstates his intelligence
also a mayor mistakenly believes British
folk in general had a high intelligence
though in his defense this was a decade
or more before the brexit vote do you
mean FBI CIA right yes Jay I'm trayful a
affiliate seriously mater were even a
tiny bit knocked on this movie could
exist though in his defense the British
intelligence agents in this movie are
basically just as much to blame since
they actually think mater is a secret
agent most of the film know some crud
hey I don't want to brag or nut
I got me a black fan today
he's pursuing cars grunt instead of you
know jumping out the window and
following these assholes like captain
winter soldier on the rooftop Oh a joke
guess I'm thin oh well when Pixar
resorts to go so you know something went
wrong this plane takes off despite a
flat rear tire and while I'm guessing
that may be possible in real life this
movie showed me the plane veering wildly
to the side after the tire blew so how
did the pilot hold it steady after that
to actually take off and how they gonna
land I didn't really wanted to leave yes
you did end of sit good agent gets what
he can and get that before he's killed
sorry why didn't the secret agent write
down some extra details if you could
only take one picture good neighbor
mater is how much did State Farm pay for
this on the one hand it's their jingle
and forever tied to them on the other
hand you actually saying mater instead
of State Farm my point is State Farm
might actually have tried to stop this
mention as opposed to sponsoring it
since it doesn't exactly make them look
good or back exactly men much help
anybody recently you're helping me
please my time this movie is a
long-awaited collaboration between
Michael Caine and Larry the Cable Guy
I guess plans are pigeons now sort of
lost track of what's supposed to be
intelligent lions and mere livestock in
this movie I can't get back to them BC
so this guy have binocular vision one
involved in this plot is one of
history's biggest loser cause that's
carsick secretly thing in two days
where's this meeting taking place portal
Gaza he thought he that's where the
Knights race yes and he I wonder what
car absolutely needs to be in the
location of every race and we've seen
his dubious backstory and is trying to
sell all and all could it be Axelrod can
survive April really I come by each one
of with my best friend Lightning McQueen
holy this movie just became the most
strictly bull imaginable you don't pop
out the dents caused by your time with
Lightning McQueen are we sure this
movie's plot was propelled by mater's
attraction to a female car because it
sounds like mater's more in love with
McQueen also I think the alternate more
believable plot to this movie would be
called e to major tambien Jean isn't
just posit you'll cover friendships can
be dangerous in our line of
me too my cocaine cuts her off before
made her as a chance to ask what she
means by cover honestly how many car
races does the Pope even go to I like
how every now and then the film cuts
back to lightening letting us believe
he's still a main character even though
he clearly is not God number of every
single joke in this movie is some sort
of car related replacement for whatever
humans use in this world stop not a
fractured nose stop measuring up on this
entire world has already explained or
implied that men and women cars get busy
and have children unless this now
implies that they go so do couples who
want children need them to be built and
if so is there some sort of pricing
where couples would want gremlins and
Pacers because they're the cheapest
children to buy and working on it
they're working on what in fact that a
heavily favored car just wrecked can you
not actually see through those things
were meant to be alternative fuels great
this moment after today everyone will
race back again early let's talk about
the villains plan fill in definitely
being Axelrod so his whole plan is to
make an alternative fuel that would
replace gasoline but create a flaw by
widgets fails publicly so that everyone
will go back to gasoline of which he
owns a lot but why do this if everyone
was already using gasoline wouldn't they
buy your oil anyway or are there many
different kinds of alternative fuel out
there besides all in all and he's hoping
that its failure will be a black eye for
alternative fuels but it doesn't make
sense either the other fuels aren't
exploded then did not see and more
importantly did not hear a helicopter
anywhere near the area before trying to
jump over can you choose your fuel for
the final race do you have any idea what
it's going to be all in all well that's
just looking stupid what we know what's
going on here but they don't all they
know is the cars are exploding for a
reason that could only be all these
assholes all pull guns on mater then
give him time to meet her tying shoes
mater is just going to keep accidentally
himself through this entire movie and
it's like I'm supposed to be all happy
because he's wearing up backpack shit
you'll kill without the other good days
okay so we're supposed to believe that
before lightning could get through the
crowd the bad guys grabbed mater and
replaced him with this evil look like
God and if that were the case then some
of these folks near him would have seen
that and would speak up this one here on
the right as a goddamn camera the bad
guys gasp mater instead of killing him
because they to have a great stake in
the toy line cars inspires
way too much of the gas induce mater
hallucination this is summon Idol right
here tying a man to a wait a second did
cars get up here to even tie him into
place so movie gives me a rage boner and
I'm gonna
or London NATO inside big Bentley
big Bentley glamour shot a big Bentley
say why did the point car Society build
all the things we have here in a real
human society okay do you moving when
mater awoke from his gasps nightmare
these two were this close to being
smashed by the next gear change but now
you want the gears to move and end up
with them even further away than where
they started this is computer animation
curse you don't actually have to accept
continuity errors you created them and
have the power to fix them these
motherfuckers move another slot closer
and yet still are a full slot away from
being crushed listen this movie is
terrible pretty much every way but the
single most terrible aspect is this gear
moving free without question makes me
want to kill we shouldn't be saying this
at all but I hope you win today movie
thinks that if it makes X over I'd say
this we won't believe he's not the bad
guy and I'm telling you right now you've
had no chance in hell though the key NP
he suddenly doesn't work because God
hates all of us and yes I know what the
movie tells us about McQueen's fuel
later that totally explains this I just
don't care he previously tested and
working laser ray to put cars running on
all in all doesn't work as expected so
they call in Plan B which is super
sudden and also a bomb planted in
McQueen's pit which is a way better
method of killing him than some kind of
laser ray anyway did you know she had
twin batteries and a front tires cuz I
definitely did not know that you may not
found on you they somehow knew that
mater would be able to get out of these
ropes by activating his machine guns
don't play so did not why not have a
bomb in the pit and a bomb on mater that
truck here's brat but I tell you what
yes you do know who that tow truck is
because he was seen with McQueen
everywhere before the first race and
he's the reason why McQueen is racing in
the first place because he called into
that show I mean to tell me there wasn't
a story about that and numerous pictures
of McQueen's best friend also mater a
tow truck is out running Lightning
McQueen who is lightning I'm back yes
mater
you are the bomb entire movie is built
around repeated asinine
misunderstandings and that makes me want
to kill something in anger like a plant
or a beetle nothing cute and lovable
obviously but still angry enough to
quell will be a sadly overestimating my
love of mater and McQueen in this series
of close calls
[Music]
movie speaks for the audience and does
so expertly even more of this what do we
do is a deceive oh you'll blow up
there's lightning blowing up skill
somehow work for the bad guys at this
point I wouldn't no one know what
happened how does this get blamed on all
Tommen powerful and rich beyond your
wildest dreams ain't going to make you
feel but citation needed yes that's just
ordinary water somehow knocking the bad
guys 100 feet back yeah it's coming from
a fire truck it's probably strong but
we're talking about the cars that we had
ton meter fuu-chan what sleek and all in
to party in Japan you'd keep in mind the
spawn had three minutes to go just
before they kick the bad guys asses
I know it's cartoon and this is what spy
movies do but it's still infuriating why
not just give him extra time so that all
the stuff they do in three minutes
doesn't seem impossible he created all
in all yeah but what if he found out who
y'all feel against the world was trying
to find sir ma'am what this brings us to
the flip side of the plan if all in all
is such a good product why can't he get
rich selling that clearly he can sell on
all and nobody gives a fit it's actually
gasoline in disguise like he's worried
that if he sold all and all for real
he'd be discovered as a fraud but isn't
he risking that very thing right now is
nobody testing this people face crazy
cheap are you idiot right bomb
deactivated
why would you make it so that this bomb
could be deactivated using only your
voice if you think there's a scenario by
which you would need to deactivate the
bomb which is unlikely why wouldn't you
think of how it incriminate you it's
official you're coming to all my races
from now on gee you're such a great guy
McQueen I can't wait for cars three nine
where you're probably a dick again for
someone known reason later cooking with
stoic British guards is everything I
hope this movie wouldn't be I made the
girlfriend oh you Arnold vestigation
prude that all in all was actually
gasoline okay so maybe this explains all
the bull about the plant as a new
product get introduced like this without
people finding out it's gasoline in the
first place plan is still stupid despite
this revelation to sell gas man still
doesn't explain how all in all would be
the end of all alternative fuels forever
either people would just blame all along
not the entire industry right why did it
take me so long to realize this movies
Francesco is just a discount John Jerome
from Talladega Nights
I'm 472 miles northwest of Dutch Harbor
captain Wild Bill wichrowski is on the
verge of a nervous breakdown anyone need
any more vino he's a little excited
lundi but I am a Frankie French
[Music]
full drawer full of them at the house
for God's sake
I bet I'm sitting on 15 $200 worth under
shorts don't be
[Applause]
[Music]